Here's a quick introduction to an
ongoing controversy about the operational
definition of language.
We'll get down to it by
asking two simple questions.
Where's language located and where
does language come from? Biology,
genetics, psychology, neurology,
artificial intelligence, anthropology,
and so many other fields have
contributed to this debate.
Great minds of even hung their hat
on one particular answer to those two
questions. In the abstract, they
have offered two main answers.
The first is linguistic nativism,
which holds that the basics of
language and grammar are innate.
This is the nature or
the internal perspective.
If things are innate, they're built
into every human being at birth.
It follows that for nativists
the origin of language.
It is rooted in the history and
development of the biological organism,
which contains the language instinct.
They point to a parent
linguistic universals shared
by all humans as evidence
for them.
Language is in the genes.
The second perspective
is linguistic empiricism.
Empiricists think that
language is entirely learned.
This is the nurturer or
the external perspective.
If language and grammar are learned,
they are features of the
organism's environment.
Empiricists point out that
we lack evidence for language
specific adaptations in
human biology and that all known features
of language match features of other
cultural developments. For them,
language is a cultural artifact.
Other options abound.
For instance,
some cognitive psychologists think that
the brain has essential equipment for
making sense of grammar against
the strong empiricists assertion.
Even if this equipment contains no
linguistic information like grammatical
categories or frameworks for pronunciation
against the strong nativist assertion.
These perspectives influenced the way
their proponents collect and evaluate
linguistic data,
our sounds and text gathered
in specific languages.
In order to study those languages,
nativists are likely to think that
since people are born with a universal
grammar, we all have an
intuitive grammatical sense.
Speakers can judge a grammatical
sentence from an ungrammatical one.
For the typical nativists you check if
a sentence is grammatical by asking a
native speaker against this empiricists
charge that actual use and not intuition
determines which sentences occur in
which do not in a given language.
For the average empiricist,
you check your sentence against a
corpus containing many examples of the
language you're asking about.
The more frequent it's appearance,
the more likely the sentence.
Okay.
The topics in my linguistics lessons
for language learners series start from
less controversial claims.
First,
the human body makes noises through the
air and marks on the page that other
humans recognize as language.
Second,
a variety of languages have been used
in a variety of ways and in a variety of
societies.
Throughout human history,
we observe difference or
change over time and space,
concrete observations of people using
language ground abstractions made based on
that data and not the other way around.
I hope you've gained some
understanding of this Meta issue.
It will allow you to
appreciate the tension between
variations and universals in
any discussion about human language.